all right I think we are alive on
YouTube what's going on people we are
alive from the new studio and I got a
lot to fill you in on I don't know
what's going on in your life I hope
things are going well and that you're
busy and happy and content and fulfilled
and all that good stuff we have so much
going on right now like my head is ready
to explode there are not enough hours in
the day and if there was ever a time for
me to find a DeLorean with a flux
capacitor so I go back in time to
arrange a few things slightly
differently so that we had a little more
time right now this would be it because
we were working so hard and of course
now we got the big three-day weekend
which was already we were we're design
right now that we're going to be working
through because there's a lots going on
so you might hear some banging while I'm
doing this and you might hear a couple
screams and some things crashing but we
are building this out so as you guys
know my my team with David and Amira
we've got a couple other people that are
that are helping us just sort of out of
the goodness of their heart we're
working hard and so what you're seeing
behind me right now is our brick wall so
that part of that brick wall was from
are set on aura they gave us some of our
set and by the way as I said a couple
times already the aura people are they
wish me the best Larry King by the way
is executive producer of my new show so
Larry and I are still friends not only
friends we have breakfast together he
does his he gets his old crew and they
have breakfast five days a week in
Beverly Hills and I officially been
invited so I've been going out to
breakfast with them they argue about
politics and sports and they tell all
jokes and it's it's really cool and fun
and and and just awesome that I'm even
included in something like that anyway
so yeah and as I've said also I may have
the licensing somebody shows back to
Laura and we can figure out some other
distribution deals and all kinds of good
stuff so it's fully it's all good and
very exciting so I'm going to show you
some of the new stuff that we've been
doing and by the way we are still
raising funds on patreon so it's
patreon.com/scishow movement report
we're over the 20k thing so we know our
our runway is good to go we really want
to hit 30 because then we can hire at
least
one more full time employee probably two
and you know get an editor get someone
to maybe do some PR we do this all on
our own all the PR all the editing all
that stuff and the more people that we
hire the more shows that we can do the
more shows that we can do or YouTube run
it money we generate the more YouTube
money we generate the more money you
have to do bigger and better we can
maybe get a small live studio audience
in here which I would love want to take
the show on the road more I want to
maybe do like a weekly news thing you
know I don't want to do the daily news
roundup because it's just so much noise
and you end up just worry just talking
about little nonsensical my new show
just for the sake of talking which is
not something that I'm interested in
doing so so we have huge huge plans so
first off what I'm gonna do right now is
I told my patreon people like people
that have donated on patreon there's
about 3,000 of you so far and for all
three thousand you you guys can consider
yourselves producers I think you
consider yourself producers of the
Reuben report that's what a producer
does or producer produces and what does
that mean that basically means you throw
the money in to make a production happen
and that's what you guys have done so
whether you've given a dollar or twenty
bucks or two fifty whatever it is per
month you've given us the runway to make
something great so on patreon right now
I sent out to my patreon people I'm
gonna answer their questions the youtube
comment section here is a total mess
I'll try to get to some of those too but
I am gonna answer all the the patreon
people first so that's the advantage
you're being in on patreon and by the
way these live videos are also going to
be part of theirs part of the tiers on
patreon we've got live chat sort of like
whatsapp with me and and whoever else
you get push notifications when I'm
online a lot of cool stuff and Skype
one-on-ones and all that good stuff so
anyway just quickly for the people that
have done it on patreon just a special
shout out and thanks to you guys because
you are you are literally making my
dreams come true like these this is
working now because of you and as I said
to you in the note that I sent you guys
a couple days ago in a different video
that I did you know when I went to bed
that Sunday night before we did this I
didn't know what the next day was gonna
bring I didn't know was it all over you
know I mean would be resigning from or
and bringing my guys with me
would it have was it gonna be the worst
professional decision and personal
decision I ever made
but and and well it's pretty obvious
that the answer's no so I'm very excited
okay so I'm gonna answer a couple your
questions that I want to give you guys a
little tour of what's going on over here
there is a lot happening at the moment
Scott wants to know my favorite band
bounces around a little bit I'd say
probably might well my favorite all-time
band is journey I love love love journey
I saw them journey live about a year ago
in Orange County I went with David and
with Kelly Carlin and we got busted for
smoking weed at a journey concert so you
know but I love journey I also love
Fleetwood Mac on a Billy Joel I love a
lot of jazz
annika saying IKEA and Target we've
bought a lot of stuff at IKEA and Target
I'm gonna show you some of it in in just
a second
let's see Joseph says what do you think
could be your greatest contribution to
political discourse I think more than
anything else it's the it's the reason
that you guys come here and I don't
think it's rocket science but I guess
these days it is which is that I like
listening to people and I don't feel
that every thought that I have is a
hundred percent correct and I don't
think that I know everything and
everyone on television knows everything
about everything
anytime something forget television
everyone in media thinks they know
everything all the time and they always
no matter what happens something happens
in North Korea they know everything
about North Korea so happens the Middle
East they know exactly what's going on
in Middle East something happens in our
government here they know exactly how
the government works and it's like it's
all [ __ ] you're all liars stop
pretending you know everything you know
we're the the best example of this I can
think of is the Cuba you know we we
unthought our relations with Cuba I
guess about a year ago now and it's like
suddenly people who I have never ever
seen once tweet about Cuba suddenly know
everything to tell you about Cuba but
it's like you're all liars and frauds I
care about having some breadth of
knowledge and there's some things I know
more about some things I know less about
and that's why I want to talk to people
because there are people that are
experts in some of these things and all
these people on the news they pretend to
know everything all the time and it's
nauseating in there and everyone's
seeing through it now to which is
actually pretty great so that is pretty
great let's see Kristen says have you
had any success converting or aggressive
a hundred percent yes
because I get emails from you guys all
time saying that you used to be far left
and then you saw on the social justice
stuff or you see or you just saw the
stuff that was happening on college
campuses with trigger wanting these safe
spaces and the constant attacking of
free speech or you saw the the
slandering of sam harris or any of that
stuff and that partly by watching my
show you thought wow there's other
people out here who think like me so
that's pretty [ __ ] fantastic
that's really [ __ ] fantastic alright
let's see what else is going on here
Christopher says if you could get any
guest does it have to be topical who
would it be and he had offered up a
couple couple great ones here
Christopher definitely knows me George
Lucas Harrison Ford Clyde Drexler Derek
Jeter I would love to have all four of
those so of course George Lucas is in my
top ten of all time so much of what I
love is was born out of Star Wars and I
just I have a seven-year-old nephew now
who's as obsessed with Star Wars as I am
he's watched all seven of them and I was
actually sitting next to him on the
couch when we were watching the Empire
Strikes Back and Vader says you know
Luke I am your father and watching like
his like world just you could see it in
his eyes just just explode and he's he
saw my dad his grandfather took him to
two force awakens so I loved loved Star
Wars so yeah George Lucas of course
Harrison Ford of course I would I mean
Indiana Jones and Star Wars and the
fugitive and he's been in a just a
gajillion great movies and and you know
he's very shy when he's on a lot of talk
shows and I know the he really likes
doing him but I think I could get him to
open up a bit Clyde Drexler I'm glad you
mentioned that one where's Clyde we got
Clyde here this is gonna be on the new
set just brought it in this morning
this is Clyde the glide when he was on
the Houston Rockets I think this is from
96 terrible Jersey but Clyde's my
favorite basketball player of all time
he was thought of really as sort of
second only to Michael Jordan but played
in Portland and in Houston pretty too
small markets or too small markets so
never got the accolades he deserved but
eventually didn't win a championship and
sort of taught me that you can do
something gracefully and and let you can
win you could win in the end so that's
nice Pat says really ever take your show
on the road I can help you if you come
to Vancouver I would love to go to
Vancouver I've never been
and I have a friend up there yeah one of
the things we want to do is start taking
the show on the road I want to do some
more on college campuses actually I'm
gonna be doing some speaking of college
campuses soon and yeah very cool brian
says fourth of July plans so we have so
much freakin work to do literally right
before we started this livestream we
were all basically like we're gonna have
to work over the weekend so we'll figure
it out I have a wedding on the third and
then I'm sure actually Kelly Carlin
throws a great July 4th party forgot
about that so we gotta we gotta get to
that thing and she has hey there's a guy
on her street
who's like a fireworks maniac but he's
also the he's in the fire department
also so he sets up probably tell you too
much information here but he sets up
what I think is probably the most
illegal and dangerous fireworks display
you've ever seen I'll videotape it and
put it on Twitter saying and it's just
awesome and insane and you know we get
really stoned it's great okay so let's
see what else is going on here
Darden fall Darden fall says Dave thanks
for everything do you think Nero Milo is
a bit reckless at times um
reckless I assume you mean that he
doesn't watch his words or measure his
words maybe as much as me uh I think
that's possible
that's possible but you know as I've
said about him many times everyone in
the in the public space does things
differently right your people that are
just sort of more provocateurs that
intentionally say things to get a
conversation going to maybe upset people
or excite people or whatever then you
have people who are a little more
measured and want to really dig into
something and unpack ideas and things
like that
and you need all of those people so
that's why my alliance with him even
though we disagree on some political
stuff it's like I think the free speech
stuff is what brings us together more
than anything else so you know and and
actually I'm gonna see him tonight
so I'll ask him what he thinks about
that Jared's his favorite band his
journey homosexuality car checks out the
journey thought of as gay
I don't think journey is thought of as
gay they were like no gay people there
really look into that Melo says he sings
journey well at karaoke there
we karaoke able band that is for sure
amos says how can we bring humility back
to public discourse where people admit
they don't know things I mean that's
what I'm trying to do I don't know
everything
I don't know why that seems so
incredibly difficult to say nobody knows
actually everyone that pretends they
know everything the more someone tells
you they know everything and they
somehow know everything about every
political topic and everything they're
really showing you that it's less it's
the less that they know and this is one
of the things look I bought liveable
I've always been the one that's always
been part of the left but this is
something where people on the left now
this regressive left this is where
they've failed miserably because I find
that they so rarely actually know
anything and they deny facts but what
they do is they get outraged so they're
so outraged and you're such a racist and
you're such you're so beneath them just
for existing but they can just make you
feel bad they can feel bad so that you
stop saying what you think it is so
dangerous and that's why we must destroy
them we must hunt them down like you
know the storm troopers find the damaged
Jedi after order 66 now that was a
reverse of the good guy bad guy
situation there so that wasn't the best
example
that's re probably strike that from the
record okay Dave is for Mel do you
recognize a specific pivotal memory when
you realize the left was regressing
there were a couple things I mean the
one that I've talked about the most and
I think many of you have said this to me
also was the moment that sam harris was
on real time because when ben affleck
called him in Belmar gross and racist in
effect you know bill who had been the
standard bearer of the left always and
always fighting for the other and for
minorities and all that and all sam did
was repeat pupils and said nothing gross
nor racist and it was so it was such a
blatant example of ben affleck this
moral indignation that was nothing it
was just nonsense and think about for
your own life if you were in an argument
with somebody how long it would take you
to tell them that they were racist right
you would never in the first two minutes
you start arguing with somebody you
would never in the first two minutes
throw out your racist unless they said
something's completely over the top
right so in that he was just locked and
ready to go with that but I thanked
Affleck now because he woke me up and he
woke up a lot of people but they were
there
things before that a lot of things on
the left eye Charlie Hebdo really where
suddenly people are saying no no no
don't draw cartoons no no no don't
offend these people guess what I'm
allowed to draw whatever the [ __ ] in
line I'm allowed to say whatever the
[ __ ] I want and my actions and my and my
words have consequences and you can use
your speech to battle my speech if you
want but guess what if you say okay
there is one thing I'm not gonna draw
there's one thing I'll ignore because if
someone doesn't want me to draw it even
though it has nothing to do with their
life they don't me drop well guess what
that's that same group of people that
doesn't want to do that they may not
want you to have they may not want gay
people to be married they may not want
other minorities to be treated okay and
etcetera etcetera so you if you give
them an inch they're not gonna say okay
look at those guys they're so great they
gave us an inch we're gonna start being
more for more progressive now and more
have more liberal ester and free
thinking values of course not they're
gonna go I see we got them they're
afraid of us and we're gonna keep taking
more and this is a huge flaw in the
thinking of people on the left it's
embarrassing and it's pathetic and I
gotta fight I yeah that's what I got to
do um let's see Mohammed says do you
notice a problem with free speech on
social media I'm not totally sure what
you mean but I would say this I notice a
problem for sure when it comes to
censoring on social media YouTube's been
doing some censorship now we know that
that twitter has been shadow banning
people and Facebook has taken down
things from X Muslims you know I've had
to help my friend Faisal out a couple
times because organizations that he's
worked with have been banned from
Facebook this is a guy whose life's work
is to help people in closed societies so
he works closely with X Muslims in these
countries and they've had their pages
taken down because they claim that their
sweet pages are hate speech and you
think how backwards this is so we really
have to guard against that stuff you
know look it's also a little bit of
unchartered territory because the First
Amendment of course is the government
coming for your free speech but as I've
said before I don't fear that the
government's coming for my free speech
anymore you could say whatever the hell
you want about the government if you
anything I said about the government
right now people go look that means
fighting the power but you're not really
at this point cuz the government's not
at the moment and I'm not gonna say one
love with the government what I'm more
afraid of is that we're silencing
ourselves because of all these cries of
racism and all that stuff
brian says on the patron and dave
skipped over my question I didn't see it
here there's a lot of questions so
couldn't say it again and I'll try to
get you
Alexes how about a pop star who likes to
get political
maybe Madonna I would love to have
Madonna on I was at one Madonna concert
about five years ago at the something
tore the something
hung up was a song hung up we've never
done a song hung up yeah whatever that
tour was and I was there on Molly
so there you go now you got a little
insider info before yeah I've only done
mildly maybe three not ever
let's see Jared wants no are you a slave
driver type of boss I guess I would have
to ask my team that would you say I'm a
slave driver I'll repeat that is that
would you say I'm a slave driver type of
boss no yeah no I'm getting a no
sometimes they have to they're better at
all the like this stuff like I can stand
here and do this but they're like it
doesn't these YouTube streams don't
magically happen walls don't magically
get up you know I put together this
thing that I'm gonna show you in a
second but yeah we just have a great
team here and I and the thing is more
than anything else and this is when
we're able to hire more people is that
it's important to trust the people that
you hire and not only trust them but
know that they're doing the right job
like these guys don't want to be me and
I don't want to be them they're they're
proud to do great the great work that
they do and that's why I love that than
them here that's how you create a good
team I think and that goes for whatever
you do goes for a sports team or or
anything else um a couple people that
something to this effect this is I&R
says any advice on how to convert or
aggressive all you can do is say what
you think that's it
that really is it we all have these
people look we all have people in our
lives and that's the good thing about
life is that you're around people who
think different things you may may not
be religious they might be religious you
might be a Democrat they might be really
but you might be for the death penalty
they might be against it and the
important thing is that you have to be
okay with having people who think
different things in your life this it
wasn't a novel concept ten years ago but
now it's starting to feel like it's a
novel concept and every time someone
posts saying that you don't like on
Facebook you yeah.he friend oh my
they ban you we got to get away from
that so I would say the moment the best
thing that you can do is argue your case
honestly and decently and not get upset
at them and not call them names and all
that stuff every time I've argued
privately sometimes with public people
that that I either was friends with or
that you may know from YouTube or
whatever I argue the same way that I
treat this and I've gotten people that
are pretty [ __ ] aggressive but I
would still say you're pretty much in
that thing by the end I've gotten them
to admit that they kind of don't know
what they're talking about and that
they're just taking this fake moral
position cuz if it came out well do you
know the history of this do you know how
this works about this a lot of their
stuff is just it's built in feelings not
fact and you can get them you can get
them but you can't be afraid don't be
afraid to be silence that's them that's
the most important thing really that
would be my number one message animus
and anything Gordon says do you aspire
to grow this venture into a new network
with other host personalities and shows
so that's sort of like one of the macro
things here so we have the micro thing
which is getting the show off the ground
which we're at we're getting there it's
happening right this very second it's
very cool and again I thank you guys all
you guys the three thousand you on
patreon I thank you for doing this for
helping me for believing me in me enough
and caring about these ideas enough to
let me try to build this thing and then
the in the bigger sense yeah we can
start shooting other shows we have a
great set up here at this studio and and
at when I was at ey T we had one hour
per week to shoot when I was at aura we
had two hours per week here we basically
have five days and a couple hours a day
so we can build this thing as big as we
want we can be going we can stream live
from the studio now we can do so much
cool stuff it will become as big as you
guys want to make it and as we can make
it and that's what's that's what's so
cool about this whether you like make
you like my Star Wars shirt okay you
don't see a grand moff tarkin doesn't
get a lot of play these days but there
you go all right a couple more and then
I want to give you then I'll give you a
little tour darden for the sigil and
sorry I'm probably over posting but I
find Jon Stewart as guilty as Rush
Limbaugh at propagating the divide you
know that's a really interesting point I
don't know that look I
first off I injured I interned at the
Daily Show in 1999 and every little
interaction I had with John was really
nice and he gave me some great advice
just sort of about the business once
which hopefully I'll get to if I can get
him on the show maybe I could repeat it
to him but it would be nice I wonder if
he even remembers what he said I doubt
it um but he has definitely done some
aggressive stuff over the years right
when I'm done with this thing I highly
recommend you guys watch the interview
that he did with ayaan Hirsi Ali about a
year and a half ago and he treated her
so poorly and was so dismissive over her
and ended it basically by by saying yeah
you just want to sell books and it's
like ayaan Hirsi Ali should be the hero
not a laugh right but of pretty much
everybody this is a woman who was born
in Somalia underwent female genital
mutilation she was gonna be forced to
marry her own cousin she escaped asylum
I think in Brussels and in Belgium ends
up becoming a parliamentarian in Holland
her want her friend Theo van Gogh doing
a documentary about ISM ISM is murdered
on the street they pin something to his
chest saying ayaan were coming after you
she now moves to the West is a is a to
the United States and now he's a
stalwart defender of all of liberal
values and you may don't have to agree
with everything she says politically to
know that this woman should be a hero
hero to everyone on the left every
liberal value ever and everyone on the
right as I said and the the regressives
treat her horribly they hate her watch
what Greenwald and Reza and jank and
these clowns watch what they say about
her and it's like you guys think about
what she lived through think about what
she lived through and she's not good
enough for you guys it's actually this
kind of thing so
oh so bad that was somehow related to
John yeah I wish he would have treated
her better in that interview so there
there you go Matt says you should have
athletic on yeah I'd love to have a look
on look I I joke about him all the time
of course and he's an easy target in a
certain way but I would love to just
revisit that moment with him because it
did wake up so many people I would love
to sit there and say to him we could
show the clip and then say you know so
what happened there like really what
happened there the problem is that he
said he's a huge star so he only has to
talk about things that he wants soon if
he doesn't want to rehash
he certainly won't okay shhh
do you know the Assassin's Creed
videogames it's heroes that are all
about fighting controlling righteousness
control freaks I didn't know that that's
what it's about I've never played it
actually but I've seen the commercials
before I should play it I used to be a
huge gamer and oh look at this I'll show
you something cool another little hint a
little in from the set here I brought
this this is gonna be on the set this is
Herzog's we from Sega Genesis I got this
I think in around 1989 this was one of
the first split-screen two players
strategy games and I've spent hours and
hours with my brother and friends in the
basement playing this game
it was sort of like a very early
precursor to like a Starcraft or a
Warcraft or all the strategy games that
people are playing now absolutely
freaking love this game I think it's
like the most underrated video game of
all time so the game is not in here
that's in my house but I got the box
here and I have a Sega Genesis
controller here too alright so let's
pause on the questions for a second just
a reminder for those of you that are
that are just on YouTube and not on
patreon it's patreon.com slash rubin
report we have all kinds of cool rewards
where we're gonna do more of these
videos so this one I'm making public for
everybody and I'm answering questions
from the patrons but soon they're just
going to be for the patrons we have the
patron app which is free we're doing
live group chat on there there are
one-on-ones with me you can get t-shirts
mugs all kinds of cool stuff and know
that you're helping ideas that I think
you care about so if you got a couple
bucks and you can jump in
patreon.com/scishow rubin report or
rubin report comm center donate that's
awesome and I appreciate it in
everything okay so now I'm going to give
you guys a little bit of a tour and I
got to be careful here because I don't
want to blow one of the big surprises
just yet I want to break my neck alright
cool so this what you're seeing here and
you know I know it's tough with lighting
and everything but we've seen here so
this is going to be behind the desk on
the set or not the desk the the table
I'm set so we'll have our low table
which you guys remember it's going to be
the same coffee table and then we just
have a lot of cool things from from
things that I need to see the studio is
really big and cool we got a great
lighting grid here we can do all kinds
of cool stuff
so you know I've got books from some of
the people that I've had on the show
there Sam and Kelly Carlin and Brooke
and Carl Sagan unfortunately I never had
on the show but I think he's watching
hopefully proud up above and you've got
some some quarks those are all from
bottles of wine that I drank hopefully
not by myself
there's Clyde the glide we got some cool
like just stuff that's gonna go on the
walls here
there's just a ton of cool stuff here
and we've got some some cameras and this
is the TriCaster over here it's down
there apparently but that's where our
mirrors magic will happen and yeah we're
just we're doing we're building this
stuff out and we're doing it by not by
ourselves because we're doing it with
you actually
but we're physically doing it like you
know we're spray paint and stuff and
that's that's the old table from the old
set we've got green screen so we can do
cool animations behind me let's see what
else this give you a little hint so this
wood that's on the floor right here
that's gonna be that's gonna be our wood
paneling on the side there's David back
there working hard oh that means I'm
gonna show a mirror for a sec she
doesn't wanna cheat as a runner she's
gonna hide she's she's literally hid she
was there she's gone now okay I tried
see that's how I know I have the right
people that I'm working with anyways we
got we got a lot of cool stuff going on
and let's see I'll jump back into the
questions for just another second by the
way not only do I appreciate of course
you know you guys that have that have
jumped in and and thrown some money in
on patreon or PayPal or whatever you did
but for those of you that don't have any
money or whatever you just don't want to
share it or whatever it is that's fine
too and if you just share the videos if
you just retweet things and share them
in your little world or not be afraid to
post them on your Facebook page because
someone's gonna call you gross and races
then then you've done you've done your
part - all right so I'm going to just
jump on and see wait can you get me back
to that put those questions back there I
lost that anyway very cool very cool
there's there's a lot of good stuff
and what else can I tell you oh so
basically so we our planet was to shoot
s shows today and then and then start to
show next week but because the compute
things got delayed and we had some
problems with this wood down here it
looks like we're in do the test shows
next week launch the week after that's
going to happen a hundred percent ok so
let's see what else here what's that oh
and then the reward for all you patreon
people you guys have been very you've
been very patient on the reward front so
we are gonna get the rewards out to you
in the next week or so we're figuring it
out should be next week so the free
right so going forward the first week of
every month will be when we issue the
rewards for the previous month and then
eventually the t-shirts will start going
out and the mugs will start going out
and all that good stuff ok got some more
questions here Levi says we'd love to
see you interviewed Dan Carlin from
common sense
I absolutely would I've tweeted at him a
couple of times haven't heard back but I
would be down to do that that guy my
libertarian friend says will you ever do
360 video interviews or virtual reality
I think it would be super cool and I'm
sure but I think we can make that happen
because my old friends at riot that some
of you guys that have been with me for a
long time I was at riot shortly between
TYT and aura they've done full in on the
virtual reality thing and I fiddled with
it there at their offices then it's so
cool I mean they've got some really
incredibly cool stuff so I'm sure I
could get them to outfit us for
something so hang tight on that Susie's
oh we got five minutes left we got five
minutes left so if you're you know it so
if you haven't jumped in on patreon
let's see what's going on here
if you haven't jumped in on patreon that
was me talking to myself that was weird
if you haven't jumped in on patreon and
you do while I'm here for the next five
minutes I'll give you a live shout out
right here while I finish this up
Jonathan says get Greg Gutfeld from Fox
I disagree with him on a lot of stuff
but I absolutely would have him on and
he actually mentioned they were
aggressive left on Fox couple weeks ago
and it was kind of bittersweet for me
because I was like that's kind of nice
like it's gay
mainstream right like the the word
itself is permeated mainstream culture
none of the other hand it's like I don't
want the right-wing to suddenly jump on
this and and and take it from us but you
know what I don't control or nor own the
word so c'est la vie
so okay cool so I'm gonna give you guys
shoutouts for anyone that jumps in while
I'm doing this for the next five minutes
Fatma and Chris and Levi and Andy thank
you guys and Ann Ann just jumped in bat
second as I said it so thank you guys
all for for being part of what we're
doing here
it's it's very cool and okay let's
finish up strong here um John says do
you worry about the [ __ ] and Auntie Jew
trolling by the all right you know my
feeling generally look I'm a free speech
guy I think if you know anything about
me at this point you guys know a free
speech guy so look I don't when I see
people on Twitter when I see what people
say oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] this bag bad or
Judas or blah blah like whatever they
want to say to me it's like I don't like
reading those things but if somebody
wants to just anonymously there are
their own that's right it's always
pepper a frog a frog with Trump's hair
or something like that and it's like you
know what if you if that's what you
wanted you alright I think a lot of
times like that's what trolling is all
about there's people that literally are
spending all day long saying offensive
things to public people just so that
they can get heard from and then what do
these public people do they retweet it
and then they go look they first up they
make themselves the victim even though
they're they're usually not really a
victim it's some anonymous wacko saying
thank you we're not even a wacko it
could be because some guy just [ __ ]
with you right like [ __ ] posting as
everybody's saying now and it's like so
I can't get that offended by that words
don't offend me
I would battle someone on the Battle of
ideas on the battlefield of ideas that's
what I would rather do but if you're
like ah you [ __ ] [ __ ] but what do we
do
alright congratulations so you want me
to get upset by a word like you know I
don't like it is that I like it well but
I think that's just kind of how it is
it's just look at the end of the day
until until you're calling directly for
violence where people are showing up my
with pitchforks because of what you've
been saying about me then I would not be
happy but short of that it's like people
I think people need to put it into
perspective I know it doesn't feel good
and I don't mean to be dismissive about
it especially if you're not a public
person I expect to get a certain amount
of this nonsense right and if you're
just if you're you know you're the
average person that's you're tweeting
about something and then just you
suddenly get a you know a barrage of
hate and it's and it's racially
motivated or sexuality motivated sign of
course it's doesn't feel good
Burma burr it's it's just words it's
just words okay cool let's see what else
here can we get a sneak peek of your
upcoming guest that's from mark I want
to hold it close to the chest on this
one because we've got a couple big ones
that I'm really working on and where
there's a lot of moving parts because
it's schedule has been a little nuts but
hang tight and I promise you won't be
you won't be disappointed Daniel Neil
says what do you think of Ken Ham he's
the creationist guy who debated Bill Nye
and I met Bill Nye for a second at the
reason rally a couple weeks ago I would
have that debate for the two of them you
know they did it already and I I suspect
that certainly Bill Nye would have no
desire to do it again but I would see
but either way I like do you like scifi
books like ah so mob have you ever read
Terry Pratchett I have never read Terry
Pratchett but I know the name for sure I
do love sci-fi almost all of my favorite
movies are sci-fi movies some of my
favorites so philip k dick wrote a
gajillion great books that were turned
into things and Total Recall which is
probably my favorite movie of all time -
Schwartz and everyone not to remake one
that was here we've got a little little
face time for Tallulah there's too
little everybody the big star here she
doesn't say she doesn't say much oh she
left you may you may have seen her
that's the studio all right they're
telling me we gotta wrap up here so all
right thank you guys thank you for doing
this with it whether you're on patreon
if you're on patreon I doubly thank you
because you're you're showing me the
money as they say and you're helping us
build this thing and it's awesome and I
appreciate it and it's very cool and
we've already I can
already like there's something new
happening here there's some like new way
of us kind of getting to know you me
getting to know you and you getting to
know me and sharing this thing together
very cool very cool and for all you on
YouTube that you share this the videos
in any way or whatever it is I
appreciate that - its fourth of July
weekend we're going to do some work but
I'm sure there will be some some Coronas
and some fireworks and all that good
stuff so I hope you enjoy yours and and
eat a lot of hot dogs and and if you're
not in America just remember you have to
celebrate the fourth of July or we might
come invade you okay
sayonara